i should tell you something else which  didn't show on the television  yeah foucault you know is totally bold  yeah  yeah the moderator fonts elders  is a very interesting person he was a  dutch anarchist  there was a dutch anarchist movement at  that time which was  doing all sorts of things like uh  giving lsd to horses at fancy  horseshoes so that they'd jump all over  the place fun of the one  on the way to the studio fonts elder  stopped at his apartment  went upstairs came down he had a  bright red wig in his hand  and through the whole debate if you  notice  closely he was nudging cuckoo and saying  put it on put it on  that is an incredible detail  that is something else